une autre fissure s'impose dans
l'horizon glacée de l'Antarctique la
cassure s'est produite dimanche dernier
22 janvier vers 19h sur l'image
satellite l'iceberg apparaît minuscule
mais la superficie du bloc de glace
s'élève à 1550 km², 15 fois à la ville
de Paris
les fissures se forment déjà depuis
plusieurs années à travers un bloc
massif dans cette région où l'épaisseur
de la glace atteint 150 mètres une glace
plus épaisse encore que la hauteur du
pont Jacques-Cartier la station de
recherche Ali a confirmer la découverte
la base se situe au nord-ouest de
l'Antarctique sur la barrière de Brand
une barrière de glace qui s'étend sur 80
km les chercheurs britanniques n'ont pas
établis de lien direct avec le
réchauffement climatique comme
l’explique Christophe quinard professeur
à l'Université du Québec à
Trois-Rivières mais la masse elle
m'avait donné s'accumule faut qu'elle
aille quelque part et c'est dans l'océan
donc oui processus tout à fait naturel
et préoccupant le bloc de glace à la
dérive va fondre et injecter de l'eau
douce dans l'écosystème des espèces
animales les organismes s'adaptent à la
salinité donc il va avoir un gros
bouleversement c'est certain pour ces
espèces là une cassure d'une telle
ampleur se produit à tous les 15 ou 20
ans les changements climatiques
devraient augmenter cette surtout depuis
les 10 dernières années
on parle maintenant de déglaciation
accélérée l'événement s'est produit à
plus de 15000 km du Québec à l'autre
bout du monde mais les conséquences
pourraient se faire sentir jusqu'ici on
peut causer une remontée de jusqu'à 3
mètres du niveau marin dans le pire des
scénarios si cette cassure isolée une
alarme pas les chercheurs le contexte
général de la fonte des glaces lui les
préoccupe grandement ici Alexis Tremblay
Radio-Canada à Montréal